hi guys today we're gonna show you an
amazing stretch for your neck okay so if
we're looking at the back of someone's
head the entire skull is attached to the
first vertebra and other vertebrates as
well but it's there's this we're going
to be working with this articulation
between the skull and the first vertebra
there's a lot of ligaments involved with
this ligaments go from bone to bone
whether you had a table an injury or
some type of injury in the past or you
just basically this the gravity stress
what we want to do is we want to
separate this out a little bit and do a
stretch to increase the space between
the skull and the first vertebra and
because this vertebra is round we're
going to be stretching at different
angles I'm gonna walk you through it so
if we're out here we'll start right here
and we'll stretch it going this way and
then here and then here like this I'll
walk you through it all we're trying to
do is create a little space in there the
back part of the skull is called the
occiput this first vertebra is called
the first cervical vertebra c1 and we're
just stretching this articulation right
here it's gonna make you feel really
really good you need someone to do this
on you I would find someone to watch the
video and you can practice back and
forth on each other it does take a
little time a couple little points is
when you put your thumb and you're
stretching sometimes people don't have
the wideness of the thumb that you might
need so you're gonna have to maybe use
part of your hand to do this or go
gentle because you have your hairline
right here and you don't want to stretch
that so but I'll walk you through it
alright check this out so here we have a
skull and the skull sits on just one
vertebra right through here c1 cervical
vertebra okay so you can see there's
these little kind of spaces right here
that this part sits on and it rotates 90
percent of the motion happens in the
first vertebra okay so if we basically
put this back through here you can see
that what we're going to do is we're
stretch the art the ligaments between
this first vertebra and the back of this
skull bone right here this is called the
occiput
so it's an occiput c1 first cervical
stretch and there's a bunch of ligaments
ligaments go from bone to bone okay
tendons go from muscle to bone so we're
gonna see these are gonna stretch the
ligaments okay so what we're going to do
is we're going to take our hand up
underneath right through here and we're
going to stretch towards this way
because it kind of got this entire skull
that is resting on a focal point right
here we want to just stretch it this way
okay so we're going to be stretching it
this way and we come up underneath and
we're going to lift up now my hands are
gonna be tucked in right here I'm gonna
lift up make sure that you don't hold
her hair and you want to take a broad
contact so you might want to use your
whole thumb right here and you come
right up and you're gonna take this hand
to help you go forward I'm exaggerating
here we're going to stretch this way
here and we'll do that three or four
times okay and then I'll kind of slowly
inch over here and kind of come up but
you could even do it like this and I'll
show you on an actual person too we're
just stretching up this way and all we
have to do is create a space in this
area and the person is gonna feel a lot
of relief okay now we're just going to
come straight here and lift up okay you
can even use your your fingers and just
do this right here and but my elbows are
nice and tucked and I'm using all my my
leverage I'm not my arms are out like
this okay
and you can come over here and do this
as well okay just stretching that head
and tucking it down this is the angle so
the angle is like this okay or you can
come over here and take my hand here and
just use the opposite side we're going
to come here and just kind of
come up I'm here if you can practice
this and get this down you can create a
tremendous amount of relief for someone
they're gonna sleep better they're going
to breathe better they're gonna feel a
lot less stress it's gonna make them
feel taller this is great from someone
that had an injury from the tailbone
injury because the force travels all the
way up and gets jammed right here so
there's a lot of reasons to do this the
only thing is if they were involved in a
car accident and they had a front-end
collision the first motion is forward
right because the car stops fast it's
going to tear these right here so if
they had this injury and then you start
stretching in that direction it's gonna
make it worse so they're not going to
feel too good so that would be only time
I wouldn't do this in which case we do
the opposite stretch we go back this way
okay back don't go forward so you'll
know real quick they're gonna go all it
doesn't feel so good good then you go
back boom problem solved all right now
let's show you on an actual person okay
this is how you do it okay we got the
skull sitting on like a little little
dish right in there and it kind of
rotates all around like this it's
sitting on the first vertebra and what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a space between the skull the
bottom of the skull is called the
occiput and the first bone so we're
going to stretch this now what you can
do is gonna take your thumb okay right
up underneath the occiput so if we look
at this here we'll take the thumb right
here and we have and it's a little
tricky because you have to kind of hook
it up right underneath that occiput that
ridge there so we're gonna take this and
we're gonna be kind of coming down with
this angle first okay what I'm trying to
do is I'm trying to lift up lift up and
flex forward now what's happening you
have to be careful because when you do
that it pulls this hair so I'm cautious
about pulling this hair I'm doing it
very gingerly here and I'm taking this
opposite hand putting it over the skull
to stabilize this force right through
here okay so we take this and we're
going to lift up
and forward okay so we're gonna flex it
up and forward this way and I'm pulling
up with the head so look at my elbow
right here it's tucked in my body right
through here so I'm like right here look
at me
um I'm not out here because I used to do
this all day long and it's
labor-intensive so I got to use my
biomechanics correctly so I'm gonna lift
up and stretch and by the way feels
terrific
does that feel good and I'm also helping
with this hand kind of tilting his head
forward because I'm trying to just take
this motion right here while I lift up
so it does require a little practice so
we're gonna lift it up right here up
underneath without stretching the hair
all right or irritating his hairline
there okay now I'm gonna inch a little
more inland right through here or up
towards the midline the angle is going
to be instead of right here the angles
now right through here lifting up this
way it helps to have big thumbs you can
see my thumb is real wide
again the you got to be careful of
messing up the hair that's the most
important thing what here so I'm lifting
up this way and I'm flexing forward so
I'm tucking his chin down this way okay
because I'm creating a stretch now I'm
right in the center and I'm gonna go
straight flex forward this way by the
way audience you can tell he's putting a
lot of effort into it there's a lot of
strength going into it but it feels
terrific yeah this is a great stretch
for sleep for neck pain for neck
flexibility full relaxation stress
reduction a lot of people have a lot of
tension
the only time you wouldn't want to do
this is if you had someone involved in a
car accident on a head-on collision
because their neck went forward first
and they tore all these ligaments so the
last thing you want to do is stretch it
more into flexion in that case if it was
a front-end collision you'd want to
stretch it back okay just do the
opposite so if it hurts the person while
you're doing this then you know it's
probably from that and just stop doing
it okay so we're here now now I can keep
going around this way but I like to use
my middle finger right here I'm not
flipping you guys off but my middle
finger with support of my other fingers
and just kind of start stretching this
way now I'm stretching it this opposite
angle this way so I'm going to lift up
and kind of come down here
you don't have to do it like that you
can use your thumb you can even use the
opposite side right here
and my thumb is underneath his occiput
stretching up and at the right angle now
I'm over here and I'm coming this way
it's a subtle motion just all you're
trying to do is a stretch it just a
little bit sometimes if your thumb is
too narrow
it can kind of be you don't have the
surface area the surface area is
actually less so Krait might be more
painful so you have to kind of go a
little lighter so adjusted based on the
person's tolerance there we go
what's the thing what does it feel like
oh it's just great a lot of strength
goes in that I can tell that's not a
subtle little mu but it just feels great
yeah when you start working with the
ligaments and tendons and stretch that
your whole body just gonna feel really
relaxed Tom's just great your breathing
will be better and this is also really
really good if he fell on his tailbone
because the forest travels from the
tailbone all the way and it gets stuck
right through in here and this is where
there's a lot of tension all right just
a tremendous process thank you dr. Burke
you're welcome and for those of you go
ahead and try this put your comments
down below tell me what you think if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos